little sparser because of the party last
night I knew that was gonna happen I was
back in my hotel where I'm hacking on
slides all right
apologies to people who were at you're a
Python I've added a couple new things
hence the hacking in the hotel room so I
am an NLP person and do lots and lots of
back-end and I'll be modeling right now
but I did do for a number of years a lot
of data visualization and so the side
projects I'm going to talk about involve
a lot of visualization partly because I
just wanted to keep playing with
front-end like pretty stuff and you get
an immediate feedback when we get
something live on the screen that you
can interact with in a way that you
don't with an NLP model so I give
invited talks occasionally and when I do
that I usually make a new talk so again
apologies that this has overlapped with
this week's talk at you're a Python so
the toys I make our toys they're like
fun distractions they're not like
professional code I'm trying to get
better about publishing my toys so that
people can see how I did them even
though they aren't really like
professional but one of my motivations
in the past few months I've been working
on really depressing stuff with hate
speech and offensive speech so I've been
sort of trying to figure out how to keep
myself entertained in my off work hours
because of the fact that my work hours
have been a little dark sometimes I
really recommend Austin cleon's keep
going which is about finding your
creative spark even in bad times the the
problem that a lot of people have in the
tech industry is that their creative
spark and their job overlap more and
more and like if you're like me and you
like hacking for fun like that ends up
being oh I could use this at work and
then they start bleeding together and
that's not always healthy we need to
like sometimes just keep a separation a
little better so these two books are
really good for thinking about that
separation so the first project I'm
going to talk about is kind of a data
analysis
data visualization project that was
based on finding something I really
liked on Twitter the Bosch bot so you
probably know about hieronymus Bosch's
the Garden of Earthly Delights which is
a really massive painting it's got three
panels on the left you've got like a
Garden of Eden scene that's like a
little bit restrained in the middle you
have I guess people having real lives
but you'll see what those lives look
like in a minute and then over on the
right you've got Judgment Day and of the
world sort of hell which is actually
pretty hilarious in this painting so
giant giant pictures so the Bosch bot is
a bot that posts a random little segment
of that picture that you can look at
zoomed in and see that detail in that
giant painting so it's a wonderful like
small data in the big data visual bot
it's fantastic and so it gets lots of
faves like lots and lots of people
follow this bot the way the way it works
sort of in the middle of your Twitter
feed of horrible Trump news or brexit
news you've got this cute picture you
click on it and it's sometimes it's a
well composed snapshot that could be a
postcard and sometimes not
you fav it so my my question as I've
been following this for months was so
what are the what are the segments of
this picture that people have favored
the most that just a general data
science question so I made an app it
obviously as many side projects do sort
of grew and turned into other things but
the essential steps that I did just so
that you can see like how fun was this
as a side project so the first thing I
did was I used a library called twin to
scrape tweets I've used lots and lots of
Twitter libraries this one's great
because you don't actually need to use
the API it's just a scraping tool and
and it's really has a great command-line
interface it's just a pleasure to use
it's fantastic so then I use pandas
obviously to load review and get the top
ten
which was
I was curious about so this is like six
months well January to May of data what
are the top 10 most liked segments in
the original Bosch bot posts it was just
the image so I was faced with if I want
to visualize this like one of my
questions is where in the image were
these little segments that's actually a
really hard problem everybody out there
who works on image problems and there's
a lot of people here who probably do
well know about OpenCV and various tools
to help you find where in images in
another image talk about that in a
second so then I used leaflet js4 a web
app to display them which I'll also talk
about in a second it's not an obvious
choice so here's the app I made let me
let me just demo it so you can see looks
exactly like the screenshot alright so
what we have here are the top 10 things
that people liked in this particular
display of this the bubble is the number
of likes it got so over here is the
number one bubble right
I added this color thing here which I
don't love but that's like how long has
it been up because I had a theory that
things that had more likes had been up
for longer and so they just got more
likes over time but but this is not dark
red it's light so it got a lot of likes
really quickly whereas these are older
okay so if I click on one I can go in
and I can see that's the actual little
image segment that got the likes a
little like that he'll landscape but
okay so let's go back here's another
good one
so see you laughed that's why this is a
fun bot and that's why this is a
fantastic painting right so when that
shows up in your Twitter feed you click
like okay so what was the number one
it was this one again laughs that's why
god faves right okay so let's go back to
talking about this
so essentially dealing with this like
okay it's easy to just get the little
top tens and say you're done but if you
want it to be like a big picture and see
where are the sections that had the
likes it's it turns out to be kind of
big data
so the actual Wikipedia high-res image
that wikipedia has mega high-res which
I'm not even dealing with but it has
this 223 megabyte big one which is the
one I'm zooming in and out on that's
that's big data and like just loading
that and not doing anything special with
it took a while and then moving around
takes a while and it cetera now the
other thing that's interesting when I
started trying to figure out where are
the little segments in the big picture
using various Python tools or image
processing libraries pillow won't load
it you get like errors about
decompression bombs and things like that
very very scary errors it turns out
later you I found out how you can turn
that off but but essentially I was like
whoa this is we're in the real world man
and then all the algorithms I tried I
have a notebook full of me trying to
figure out how to register the little
image and the bigger image crashed my
laptop ran out of memory took forever
now remember I could have like uploaded
this to the cloud and like thrown like
lots of resources at it but it's a side
project right anyway I might still go
back to doing that but essentially all
of the algorithms I tried didn't didn't
work well on this part of the reason
they don't work well is that there's
this is not a photograph it's a painting
so the lines on the features are blurry
and there's also paint chip like things
going on everywhere so you have all
these extra artifacts that make it even
harder that the the algorithms are
confused by all the paint chip stuff and
so they highlight those those features
but if anyone's good at doing this with
a neural net I'd like to talk to you
afterwards
so I ended up actually finding where the
top ten were in by hand in Photoshop
which is embarrassing but it was super
super easy because Photoshop has tools
that will let you know where the XY is
and the widths and Heights of a segment
and then I just like overlaid and
transparency and figured out where they
were and rescaled because sometimes
these things were not the same scale
which is another reason that it's hard
to figure out where like with code where
you are in the image so so I said I used
leaflet to display this thing why
leaflet is a mapping tool like it's it's
for making maps tiled Maps tiles are how
you handle the display of the really big
image so a map is is essentially
multiple zoom levels and at each zoom
level you have different sized
breakdowns of the big image and the the
library that you use or Google Maps or
whatever handles the transparent zoom in
and out pan across by loading the right
tile at each zoom level leaflets really
good because it's been around for a long
time so it has a lot of tools for doing
UI with big images what I had to do was
to essentially make leaflet treat this
like a map so there's like weird code in
here that the changes from like a
Mercator map projection to just a roster
image coordinate system leaflet now has
added tools to handle big images like
this without needing to do that
translation but but I did the
translation with with someone's library
so to convert your big image to map
tiles there's something called G Delta
tiles PI that has a lots of nice command
lines there's a bunch of explanation of
how to do it so after I was done I had
at the top level the zero level
I had one image which is the big picture
you see and at the bottom zoom level
which is seven for me I have seven
thousand nine hundred and six images so
it's broken up into all these little
tiles and then you have all the
intermediate zoom levels with different
numbers
segments of that image so the other
thing about using a library like leaflet
even though it's a mapping tool is that
it has tons of stuff for like like a
rollover tool tip I can pass data in I
can click on it and then get into a
different display where I show a
different marker which is the like
square border thing that shows the
actual actual image and like I said that
was the number one fave so at a certain
point I got in touch with the author of
the Bosch bot mr. Hermes Bosch bought
herself and and I was like look how are
you making your little image tiles like
which resolution did you use like I just
needed to know what's going on here it
turned into a really productive and
interesting conversation and this came
up so it turns out that that is the
pinned image on the account page and so
that's one reason it has the most faves
people go to that page for the bot and
they see that and they fav because it's
hilarious right but the other thing is
that a celebrity went there so I he or
she and I did not know who this was but
this there's like this this Hollywood
celebrity comedian who went there and
retweeted that image and it became viral
and like so he has like or she has like
the Bosch bot has 35,000 some followers
now partly because of Karen Kilgore
so so again unfortunately because of
social media
just because someone faved the picture
doesn't mean that it's because that was
the coolest picture although obviously
fat but guy on a fish is the best
picture still so so because I was
talking to the Bosch bot about this
problem of trying to figure out where
the image was in the big image they
added the actual like coordinates in the
width and height to the posts they
aren't as pretty and they might end up
putting them into a sequel database that
I can use in the future but having added
them I can now I can now work with them
so this is what I was doing in the hotel
last night since they added them to to
the posts I scraped all those which is
like a month and a half or a couple
months and this is where the this is
where the likes are where the images
were and where the likes are and how old
they are so there's no longer a pattern
really going on where there's more likes
going on over on the right panel which
is what I saw in the top 10 but 10 isn't
a big number of data points right so so
this is my first look at this I was like
wow this is sort of out of control and
then after a certain point when you zoom
in and you start seeing the borders and
you see how much they overlap and the
transparency isn't working this is where
I went to the date of his uiu exposition
of this needs a new redesign like this
is just not the right way to show this
because it's not ten points anymore this
is now something that needs real app
controls to filter to handle the volume
differently that I did make one
adjustment that made it slightly easier
to look at which is this instead of just
doing color by day's posted I did the
ratio of likes per day's posted so
essentially like a dark red one had had
more likes per day and that that allows
certain things to pop up that are more
interesting potentially so so I'll do a
quick demo of that one so this one for
instance is that now as soon as I
clicked on that and saw that everything
of course that had a lot of likes like
it's obviously hilarious alright but so
here's a home button by the way but the
code work in progress
I haven't solved all of the resetting of
boundaries and things but so over here
we have another one that's really again
like of course that had a lot of likes
it's awesome so you know whereas like I
don't know more random one that's
obviously random like it's not as cool
as the ones I just showed so so in a
sense the bigger data with the more
votes and then legs per day is actually
paying off but it's not a it's not a
finished app that's a in progress okay
so some related work if you're
interested in big that big image display
the pudding which is a data
visualization publication that does
great work with and makes original
datasets they use this tool called open
sea dragon to do they're sort of tiling
panning display of best-selling book
covers the the library is cool it's just
the because it's not like a library
that's got a lot of UI tools with it all
it does is the panning and zooming right
there's you don't get any tooltips for
like you you essentially have to add
stuff or add extensions or write your
own stuff so it's it's quite cool this
by the way is a TSN a layout square F ID
using roster fairy from Mario Clingerman
so if you're interested in that kind of
display the link links are in my slide
here okay so let's talk about another
couple of things so I'm an NLP person
and I'm interested in visualization
obviously we're Tyvek is more
visualizable than current transformer
based embedding language models so i've
been playing a bit with for Tyvek over
the years so not lots of you probably
know the details where Tyvek is
essentially this concept that's the it
encodes in in a you know matrix the
context of words used in a corpus it's a
it's actually a very simple simple
language model these embeddings they
aren't they aren't particularly strong
at understanding how to deal with words
in different contexts which modern
transformer based models
um so I use Project Gutenberg a lot it
is fair use out of copyright text and
it's got this like old like 1980s style
website that's really horrible but
everything comes in multiple versions so
there's like a Kindle version plain text
ePub HTML versions so it's a great place
to get text data if you want to do
modeling now there are a bunch of
libraries including a lot of Python
libraries for getting text off of
Gutenberg in a more automated way I
actually used David Robinson's Gutenberg
or our package it's a little out of date
I should warn you but among all of the
packages I've looked at that's the one
that allowed me to query by subject so
if you want to do things like get all
the fairy tales all the detective
stories all the ghost stories you can do
that using using this package but you
have to update it so that means you have
to download the latest metadata tables
rebuild them and and I had to actually
change a little bit of his code to to be
able to get the right info out of the
tables I I'll probably talk to him about
about getting my changes in or forking
it or something because it's a really
useful library so if you haven't done
the building a word to Veck model the
simplest way to do it is to use Jensen
and Python these are this is the
relevant bit of code if you haven't done
it and don't want to look for the in
online tutorial the essentially what
Jensen wants is your corpus has to be
tokenized sentences so you need to have
everything a list of or some generator
that's gonna yield tokenized sentences
and the training model is super easy
obviously there's parameters you can set
here that like the window and things
that you you can play with and then you
can get access to the vector for each
word you can do things like get most
similar which we'll see in a second the
key things here are saving the model
loading the model so if you want to use
your model in other contexts you're
gonna want to be able to save it and
then load it so one of the things a lot
of people do with word Tyvek is make
these two dimensional cluster plots to
show that essentially words that are
used in similar contexts end up
clustered together so this is just a
quick demo to show you what it's like
playing with one of these so this is
this is the fairy tales and folk tales
that I collected for a model and I ran
you map and the code is linked off I put
off the gist that I use the code is
linked off of the slides so you can make
one of these really quickly yourself so
for instance if i zoom in this is plotly
if i zoom in on these you'll see that
there's a lot of like number words
grouped together 13 7 18 so what this
means is that actually the the models
not too bad it actually figured out that
all the numbers occur in similar
contexts in folk and fairy tales right
five few fifty over here previous 15
19th fourths second first okay let's go
back over here we have easier more
greater bigger harder which is great
brighter deeper so frequently you end up
with words that are same part of speech
together over here we have like
old-fashioned words seus hast mayst
Scheldt etc so there's some pretty old
fashioned texts in this collection as
you might imagine
alright the lighter ones are words that
occurred more frequently in the corpus
because this script that I it's a script
from Peter Baumgartner that I added to
adjusted it counts up how many times the
word appeared in the corpus so you can
see the the more common words are our
lighter colored here okay so
the here's the link to the gist so one
of the common things obviously with word
Tyvek is that you can find most similar
terms so in this particular person's
example we have the word polite and the
closest words with a distant score are
courteous friendly cordial professional
attentive gracious so so essentially
what we're doing is looking at usually
cosine similarity in the matrix you're
looking at like relationships between
vectors sorry nevermind alright so what
essentially what I was interested in is
what if we what if we just sort of chain
words together this is the toy part what
if we go like closest word too polite
which is courteous and then look up
courteous what's the closest word to
courteous
it's obviously not going to be
necessarily friendly it's gonna be
potentially something else so what if we
just keep chaining like that and then
look at what those word chains lead to
so I made an app so this is this is the
word fire sorry about the size for you
guys let me see if I can so it's not
it's it's easier to see but it's not as
pretty so if we look at the word fire
the closest word in the in this model
which is the Guttenberg poetry model
burning folded lids curls etc let me go
back to glossy velvet etc so we read it
like that which is what that swoop is
supposed to show and the distance here
says that that folded is further from
burning than curls is from lids okay so
what we're seeing is how far the
distance measure says and we can do the
same thing in a different model so this
is fire in an in a Gutenberg poetry
model this is fire in a poetry model
that includes more recent work so let's
take a look we have a close a closer
word flame is closer so we've replaced
the closest model is when we added a
bunch of works to the corpus and we get
different distances in different words
so this is so this is wind storm rain
wind mist sunset as I said just now so
the vertical distance represents the
distance in the in the vector space that
score that you get when you do most
similar-sized is how often the word
shows up in a most similar search so I
wanted to rule out cycles because
they're really boring to look at they
aren't interesting informational II so
all I did was if you get if you get
sunset as the next most current word I
just go back to the first occurrence and
increment the count and then increase
the fontsize right and the color is here
is just to be pretty and to sort of show
that you're going we're reading from
left to right so like I said there to
poetry models so in January of 2019 a
huge number of really interesting things
were released into they came out of
copyright and we're added to gutenberg
including a whole bunch of really
important cool poets like modernist
poets so the mod the model actually
changed a fair bid we saw that with fire
and it's really interesting to me to be
able to compare those models with the
extra works so believe this is believed
in the older poetry model we had learned
grieve suffer choose understand in the
newer model after we've added the modern
poets we have supposed believe right etc
but somewhere down here we get magazines
which is hilarious and shows that this
is this is truly a different model
alright so I decided that those sort of
eleventh-hour that let's add something
totally different let's add like like
nerd Tyvek is a model that you can just
download off this this dudes website
it's Star Trek Star Wars and Doctor Who
and it's super different from the poetry
Gutenberg model obviously
so in nerd Tyvek when you search for
believe you get discover think realize
continue these are not poetic uses of
the word believe right now that project
I did I did a while ago like six months
ago
I updated it with these new models and
the radio button fairly recently because
I wanted to be able to compare model
visualizations but one of the things I
was sort of aiming at eventually was was
using those words avec models and the
distances in a kind of a creativity
aiding tool so I'm super interested in
found poetry and and other things so
this is blackout poetry you've got a
text you black it out but you leave
certain words visible Austin Kleon made
this miss this very popular this is some
of his examples he has a book on it
actually this is old-school cut-up
poetry where you take different texts
and you combine words this goes way back
to the Surrealists and a bunch of other
older non digital poets so that's by
Timothy David gray this is an example of
a poem by Resnick off that is using
legal reports and taking sentences out
of legal reports to construct a poem
which is brilliant depressing brilliant
so I'm inspired by these kinds of things
and I also was kind of like well what if
I want to mess with these open source
poems remix and mashups are fine now
their fair use right so I made a demo
where a toy where you load a poem and
then you use a word to Veck model to
mess with some of the words in the poem
so let me increase the font for you guys
so this is Robert Frost and we have
different words avec ma tools here and
I'm using kind of a dumb library
algorithm to find nouns in in this text
in a kind of sparse way but so
essentially if I click on woods
I can pick words from the older poetry
word to back model and replace so whose
woods are these let's go with whose
Hills are these and now I have a
different poem right his house is in the
village his house is in the churchyard I
can't see because it's too let's make
his house in the churchyard anyway you
get the point so so this this turns out
to be more fun with shorter poems so
I've added a bunch here I could allow
people to upload their own but actually
this one is interesting so so this is
this is a war poem so Carl Sandburg the
strongmen keep coming on I think I'll
change that to women notice how in the
older poetry model Kings are closer to
men than women are strong women keep
coming on what do the women do so it's
not always the same part of speech right
there are word Tyvek models that are
annotated with part of speech info this
one is not
they go forth this is women okay
so let's change the model this is the
more modern one it's still Kings there's
just enough stuff in the Gutenberg
poetry corpus that even adding the more
modern stuff women is not the now we
have people before we get women all
right okay so let's go to folk and fairy
tales so now we get women but notice
warriors shows up dogs show up in here
giants because it's a [ __ ] fairy tale
model right okay nerd to vac women
guards soldiers troops there's a lot of
fighting in a Star Wars Star Trek and
Doctor Who all right so I actually find
this kind of fun which was the goal I
was after so so the color here
represents a normalized distance between
the original word and and its next
closest relative so essentially if if
it's a pink word that means that the
next closest word and most in the word
Tyvek model is actually kind of far
relative to the others so that means
like maybe this is gonna be super
interesting to click on maybe not now so
so as I just demoed this is largely for
the slides so you've got your bash Oh
haiku which seem to be kind of the the
funnest to play with to be honest the
old pond frog leaps in waters hush it's
actually water sound because it's what
the original was so now this is an
interesting one so in in old pond frog
leaps in water sound so if I click on
pond here and I'm in the nerd to bec
model this just goes to show you
how sort of week these these embeddings
are what I get is a whole bunch of
proper names because Amy Pond and dr.
who essentially over there there aren't
enough uses of the word Pond in Star
Trek Star Wars Doctor Who etc for pond
to be like body of water instead Pond is
associated with Rory and a bunch of
other character names because that's how
simple these words avec bottles are
alright so just just so you understand
the color thing if you don't know about
d3 d3 makes it easy to do these mappings
of numbers to color ranges it's one of
the most useful things all the scaling
that you get for visualization so in
JavaScript essentially what you're doing
at c3 as you're saying my domain is the
lowest the farthest away word in the
words of Baek ma tell the distance score
and the closest score that I got and
then I'm mapping that to this color is
farthest away this is closest or vice
versa depending on what you want
anchored where now the I mean I built
this with react because I wanted to play
with like a modern web framework cuz I
haven't I haven't done JavaScript for a
job for a while now so react turns out
to be really really a pain I could have
done this really fast in just playing
playing JavaScript like bass JavaScript
maybe with some jQuery and d3 of course
so so the app involves all these
different component levels it's like all
the way down to like the Select list so
you have the app where you have your
dropdowns
you have the poem itself then you have
each line of each poem you have the
little like clickable words you have the
modal that pops up you have inside the
modal you have the list that you pick
with the radio buttons and and then
after you choose one and you close it
you have to pass the state all the way
back up to redraw the poem with the word
that you chose okay now originally when
I wrote this I put
the API call here to the words avec
model at the modal so click on a word
get the relatives like that's obvious
right the problem is I wanted to
visualize the distances so I wanted to
have the colors on all the on all the
words so you could see that this one is
has a neighbor that's further away than
this one so I had to put the call up at
the poem level and then it was like here
I am with 20 words looking up all the 10
closest and getting the distances to
redraw the poem it was it was that was
hard like there were a lot of promises
going on it was really kind of a pain
and then in the end I'm not sure the
colors are actually super useful or
interesting because the distances aren't
that far most of the time so that was
one of those like date of his
experiments that probably didn't pay off
that well and react like it is a pain in
the butt in a lot of ways so this is
this is a guy posting this is how you
pass state down and react with 4.1
thousand likes and this is the video if
I'm connected to the Internet
this is seriously programming and react
this is what my code looks like that's
what my code looks like okay but like I
said the batch of haiku are kind of fun
cuz they're short so here's here's the
original version here's me having used
one of the poetry models the last wet
shower even the basil seems to try a
little cap of dirt which is very pretty
and cute and feels like a good haiku the
words of Ekman all the last hot meteor
even the lizard seems to need a little
robe of guts so with the right model you
can get some really different results
okay so if we look at the parts of this
project so the words of Echols easy I've
done them a lot coding the poem and
reacts yeah easy to make a decision like
that but then like really hard learning
curve because of all the different
components I had to build in all of the
state that I had to pass up and down all
the time this this was this was hard
changing the stack to get the distance
versus for all the words as promises
that was that was super hard novice
reactor program I remember doing the
color scale on the buttons was super
easy and even plugging d3 and to react
was easy so that was fun
adding so at a certain point late before
the talk I added the dropdowns to change
the model and to to change the poem that
actually was not so hard so I that was a
point where I was like well maybe that's
why people use react because adding
components to the page or making a made
what looks like it might be a major
change maybe isn't if you've got the
right framework going on
so some related work lots of you know
about GPT to
things where you can sort of start start
a text and then complete it with with a
word model hugging face has a nice right
with transformer model up there where
you can play with play with the
completions from GPT - it's actually
only ok lots of things are not
grammatical or don't make sense with it
this is I've put the slides up so you
can look at look at this later but this
is me trying to write something somewhat
sensible with GPT - and the blue is the
completions from the model and and the
white is me and it's funny but bizarre
so I like I'm still not quite sold on
these things maybe the really big GPT -
model is better so in the visual space
there are other tools like Nvidia's
Gauguin demo is cool you can sort of
draw something kind of crap and with the
colors indicate whether you want it to
be cloud mountain grass sea or whatever
and then it will like photo real render
it for you it still doesn't look good
other people are better at the drawing
part of this I think so I've seen some
really amazing seascapes or whatever but
I think like you have to be drawing
something that's quite similar to what
it was what it was built with in terms
of modeling I'm sorry and then one of my
favorites though is the Gann breeder app
so the Gann breeder app is is this cool
like toy whatever thing so you can't use
start on the homepage with like here's a
cool animal you click on one that you
like and then you can generate children
and sort of control relationships
cool and then you can crossbreed with
with images or edit the genes so the
genes that way
into this our peacocks red shanks I
don't know what half of these things our
gray fox cricket fox squirrel so let's
up the cricket nests let's up the
guacamole let's turn down the I don't
know what that is make a child's okay so
so so you see that this is a guacamole
cricket thing very very different from
this and then you can like fav and then
and then go and play with you some more
so these are castles that I made because
I'm obsessed with castle generation so
like there just aren't enough
architecture examples in the set so
hopefully when this person updates this
tool it's going to have even more castle
generation possibilities yes
alright so fine make use cool datasets
the the I mean obviously has a date of
this person and data analyst originally
I like datasets but I think you can be
like super creative about your datasets
to things sometimes things are data that
you didn't know we're data the there are
however ways to find datasets if you
don't know how to how to think about
data as differently
Jeremy singer vying as a data journalist
who has a great mailing list called data
is plural which documents weird
interesting data sets that people have
told him about her he has found there's
also an archive of datasets there I have
a giant I obsessively collect links on
pin board I have one for datasets that
has has things that she wouldn't
necessarily think of as datasets and
then like make your own remix fair use
content like like Robert Frost now this
is an example of a cool project side
project by Josh Stephens who's a mapping
date of his person
this is Bigfoot sightings in the US and
Canada obviously no one paid him to make
this but I'll tell you what this was all
over the news like he he has a lot of
press for this it's also a very good
data viz
Janell Shan so I added this recently
Janelle Shane is the kind of the hero of
creative uses of AI for text generation
she's totally worth a follow I added
this cuz I'm in England and you guys
might laugh at this if you show this in
Europe no one no one knows why it's
funny this is like pubs from the north
of England generated by a neural net so
you know we have the rat horses we
travel which is actually a pretty weird
pub name but some of these are really
like could really be old fester Lin burn
horse hotel dass of bullying of stank
clearly that could be a pub right lunes
hall the all house are sin
she said a lot were pornographic so
anyway I would recommend going and
reading her article about this she she
gets sent weird datasets all the time
including smallish text datasets and
then turns them into gold this is one
you would not think of this as a dataset
but again like if you think creatively
about what data is and what a data
project this crazy person alphabetized
all the scenes in The Wizard of Oz so
let me just so the whole thing including
the credits are alphabetized I don't
know why I mean but like but essentially
it gives you a different appreciation
for the movie and he's toad like of
course he used code to do this like at
first I was like wow that's some insane
editing job and then I read the article
it's about code so whoops sorry I have
to have to advance differently so so
here's the point about this he says that
his appreciation for the film increased
because he's looking at it as small data
like he's looking through every single
clip in word right
just like the Bosch BOTS and just like
any fun database project where you have
to spend a lot of time on the details of
the data so that's one reason I like the
artistic uses of data because you
especially like if you're editing a poem
by Bosch oh you think about your choice
like if I'm replacing a word from a
famous Japanese haiku poet what am i
replacing it with and in the choice of a
Guttenberg poetry model I'm looking at
like words that came from other poets so
so it's it's not so bad but
there are other other cool datasets out
there that have been used in AI art in
particular so Viktor Dibya curated and
cleaned thousands and thousands of
African mask images in order to do Gann
generation of African masks so that's
that's a wonderful project and a Riddler
took photos of tulips to generate tulips
that have never been seen before and
just this collection of photos of tulips
is itself a massive massive data art
project so that's the link to her
generated tulips if you want Helena
Helene esaron does gann art using
drawings and photography she doesn't use
other work she uses her own work and and
it's all really beautiful and really
interesting this is a poem by Mary
Oliver pay attention be astonished to
tell about it which i think is wonderful
inspiration this is a project that I
still haven't had a place to talk about
that I think is hilarious this is this
is data in a in a weak sense it's it's
using translation models so each of
these blobs is a speaker of a different
language and they run into each other
and they use machine translation
algorithm to convert what they said into
the other language and you get a chain
of bad translations that are hilarious
this was a really fun project the
conference I did this for was cancelled
and so I didn't get to talk about it so
if anyone wants to have me come and talk
about this I thought so but if you're
gonna do this don't be a jerk give
credit to your sources help each other
especially inspiration from artistic
sources that matters to write like
credit who inspired you but really like
don't be this deep nudes guy I mean I
shouldn't have to say this but just
because if I don't do it someone else
will do it in a year is not a good
reason for a project especially a side
project what the hell
okay the algorithm only works with with
women because images of nude women are
to find online be more creative right
and now this is all over github all
their github set its taking it down okay
so I want to reiterate that like this is
my patio in France like the pots are
work right like I I plant all these
seeds and it's they're growing there but
it's it's essentially work to keep them
alive I have to water them all the time
it's very very hot and Leo but meanwhile
like one of my one of my potted plants
dropped a seed over the edge this is
this is just so ironic to me a seed from
a plant that died in a pot landed on
gravel under here with no Sun no water
from me this is one plant take a look at
it I mean it's like doing so well it's
doing way better than anything I keep
alive like and I just feel like a
failure and a success when I look at
this right this is this is amazing to me
put your stuff out there even if it's
kind of garbage e-code I'm trying to do
better I thought myself max Kaminsky
who's a game designer and fascinating
character has a reminder here if
inexperienced creators are using your
tool to turn out loads of half-baked
garbage your tool is a phenomenal
success you too can have lots of people
making half-baked garbage with your
stuff if you want which I do so I went
through a creative coding course and I
did this as my final exercise it was an
online thing I posted it saying Matt
your course was amazing this was like
weirdly popular all it is is emoji
Smiley's people loved it cuz it's it's
fun right so just make things that make
you laugh and share them and make other
people laugh so I would like to give
thanks to a lot of people including the
Bosch bots for this I couldn't have done
all of this without the Bosch BOTS Peter
baumgartner's just like crappy sketchy
code right got me a plotly interactive
view map for this talk in no time at all
so I paid it forward by updating it with
some more stuff the word Tyvek api code
I could have wrapped that of words avec
models in a flask API myself but I
didn't have to because this person had
posted some code I got a little help
from a friend with react when I was
moaning about it and this person here
posted a comments on the u map library
with how to import it if you have an
import problem many many people have
profited from his comment let's all help
each other out anyway there's my
credentials and some more of my writing
about AI art and data vis if you're
interested and these slides are up at
this URL with the links and things not
the projects they're all local demos
still but I'll work on getting them
online thank you very much
[Applause]